io sono uno sperimentatore rompiscatole
perché perché tutta la mia carriera
professionale è stata dedicata alla
ricerca scientifica sia in campo
accademico che in campo industriale e
perché le persone che mi conoscono me lo
dicono tu sei un rompiscatole
c'è chi dice che sono un forte e
rompiscatole c'è chi dice che sono
semplicemente un rompiscatole bene
fermiamoci un attimo pensate ciascuno di
voi è uno sperimentatore ciascuno di voi
ogni giorno sperimenta deve prendere
decisioni analizza adatti fa delle cose
fa delle scelte
quindi voi siete tutti sperimentatori
noi siamo tutti sperimentatori e sono
sicuro che almeno qualcuno di voi è un
gran rompiscatole e tutti almeno qualche
volta siete stati dei rompiscatole o un
buon sperimentatore rompiscatole
adesso mi chiederebbe e vaime ma cosa
c'entra col pensiero laterale allora
cerchiamo di vedere se riesco a
convincermi
io credo che oggi la sfida che abbiamo
di fronte un mondo estremamente
complesso estremamente diverso dal
passato richiede il cambiamento di
paradigma con cui siamo abituati a
lavorare prova per cambiare questi
paradigmi dobbiamo uscire dagli schemi e
uscire dagli schemi non è facile e
pensiero laterale è uno degli strumenti
con cui possiamo ragionare e io quello
che cercherò di fare e di darvi la mia
esperienza su due aree su cui da un po
di tempo ragiono in termini di schemi
diversi e sono le aree delle
organizzazione della scienza e della
tecnologia
però prima di entrare nel merito
un bravo sperimentatore
se rompi scatole si guarda al suo
interno cerca di capire qual è
l'elemento che gli permette di essere un
buon rompiscatole
allora io ho imparato ancora una volta
era esperienza che io sono e credo
ciascuno di voi e contemporaneamente
conservatori innovatori e queste due
tensioni sono molto importanti nella
maniera in cui facciamo i rompiscatole
perché siamo conservatori siamo
conservatori perché noi siamo esseri
sociali
noi entriamo in relazione con le persone
senza questa relazione noi non saremmo e
quindi abbiamo bisogno di essere
accettati di far parte di un gruppo
questo ci condiziona tendiamo a essere
omogenizzati dal gruppo a cui
apparteniamo e in generale questo è uno
dei grandi problemi del nostro tempo
accettiamo rifiutiamo priori
oggi c'è una grande difficoltà ad
ascoltare e invece dobbiamo ascoltare e
un volo umpi scatole prima di tutto un
grande esportatore e c'è un elemento
molto importante quello che noi non
conosciamo pensiamo che non esiste il
che naturalmente non è vero ma questo ci
rassicura perché c'era sicura
permettetemi una piccola divagazione il
cervello è un organo ad altissima
richiesta energetica il cervello ha
bisogno di tantissima energia e quindi
come tutti i sistemi nell'auto energia
tendono a stare al livello 1 gerico più
basso possibile
questo elemento di conservazione
allo stesso tempo e qui gli antichi
avevano capito gli antichi hanno capito
molte cose
fondamentalmente sulla base
dell'esperienza che se io occhio
utilizzano energie per pensare io
infatti da un po di tempo faccio sempre
alloggio dell'ozio odiate
la prima persona che ha parlato vi
parlava del sonno e la stesso concetto
bisogna dedicare energia al cervello ma
siamo anche innovatori siamo innovatori
perché noi ne abbiamo innata curiosità
nel conoscere e la nostra identità
attenzione quando noi cerchiamo di
conoscere e poi arriviamo a quella che
definisco generalizzazioni e c'è sempre
un elemento è un rompiscatole deve
ricordare che nella giornali d'azione
c'è sempre l'eccezione e quindi noi
lavoriamo con l'istinto critico ora cosa
mi dice l'istinto critico e quindi la
capacità di uscire dagli schemi
mi dice mi parla della diversità noi
siamo esseri umani mangerà la natura
quel che siamo per via della diversità
se non ci fosse la diversità non saremmo
quello che siamo
ora la diversità è un concetto molto
complicato ed è molto difficile mettersi
in relazione a diversi temi ma se non
accettiamo la diversità vendiamo non
andare avanti allora perché ho scelto le
organizzazioni come un'area di
discussione
io credo che le organizzazioni oggi
rappresenti uno dei grandi limiti
all'identificazione di nuovi paradigmi e
quando parlo di organizzazioni parlo di
macro organizzazioni come gli stati
organizzazioni medio come può essere
un'azienda o anche alle micro
organizzazioni la famiglia i piccoli
gruppi sociali
innanzitutto perché ci organizziamo
perché abbiamo imparato abbiamo imparato
che è meglio essere organizzati che non
essere organizzati e quindi
l'organizzazione è uno strumento è uno
strumento che
aumenta l'efficacia e l'efficienza
attraverso i quali raggiungiamo degli
obiettivi attenzione in natura non tutto
efficiente
ci sono molti sistemi che non sono
efficienti ma sono efficaci noi oggi
tendiamo troppo a dare importanza
l'efficienza allora si consolino un'idea
l'organizzazione le studiamo creiamo gli
esperti e succede un fatto un corto
circuito che secondo me è molto
pericolosa e che pensiamo che se creiamo
l'organizzazione perfetta noi risolviamo
tutti i problemi
a questo punto succede questo
cortocircuito per cui l'organizzazione
diventa il fine non ci porta più quello
che per cui abbiamo creato dall
organizzazione perché è un po contro
intuitivo ma pensateci bene perché se io
penso che l'organizzazione mi permetterà
di raggiungere il fine l'obiettivo
questo diventa il fine stesso ho sempre
delle grandi discussioni con gli esperti
con le persone che le aziende in cui
lavorato si occupano esempio di risorse
umane perché loro naturalmente mi dico
ma non sono mica stupido lo so che
l'organizzazione non è un fine e io dico
ma devi guardare come agite non è tanto
come pensate come si agisce e oggi
l'azione nell'ambito dell'organizzazione
tende a farmi dire che l'organizzazione
rischia di essere il fine e quindi è un
bel problema
vi faccio un esempio prima il motivo per
cui questo avviene è perché io credo che
noi guardiamo le organizzazioni come
macchine ma ricordati persino le
macchine possono sbagliare ma una
macchina una sua logica una coerenza
interna ma l'organizzazione non è una
macchina e un organismo è fatta di
persone e questo determina il fatto che
l'organismo a interazioni molte di
queste interazioni non sono prevedibili
vi faccio il caso della scuola
ho scelto il credo della scuola perché
oggi tutti parliamo di educazione
oggi tutti diciamo che la conoscenza
della cosa fondamentale oggi diciamo che
per essere competitivi dobbiamo essere
più bravi degli altri nella formazione e
allora tutti parlano di riforma della
scuola in tutti i paesi e non solo in
questo paese questo paese abbia un
problema che facciamo riforme ogni anno
ma questa è un'altra questione
ma quando facciamo e parliamo di riforma
della scuola noi parliamo e non andiamo
a guardare come organizzata la scuola
allora vi consiglio chi non ha mai visto
questo anime it della royal society of
art di ken robinson che spiega come è
nata la scuola la scuola innata per le
esigenze della rivoluzione industriale
ebbene quando ho visto questo anime c'è
una cosa fantastica che ovvia ma che io
non avevo capito pensiero laterale
noi prendiamo bambini di 5 6 anni e
pensiamo che hanno la stessa capacità di
apprendimento e gli stessi interessi
beh nell'ottocento forse questo poteva
essere pensato oggi sappiamo
perfettamente che a quell'età è l'età
dove la capacità di apprendimento è
estremamente diversa da individuo
individuo e soprattutto gli interessi
sono completamente diverse e noi cosa
facciamo li mettiamo tutti in un corso
che di fatto cosa fa tagli talenti
signora è questa una discussione che ho
anche una volta all'interno delle
aziende in cui lavoro con soprattutto le
risorse umane in tutte le aziende che
siano grandi o piccole ci sono processi
complicatissimi per identificare i
cosiddetti talenti dobbiamo identificare
i talenti perché la soluzione non i
problemi sono identificare le persone di
talento
io ho sempre rivoltato questo concetto
l'organizzazione serve a far sì che si
possono esprimere i talenti di ciascuno
ciascuno di noi ha talenti e nella
scuola noi togliamo la capacità dei
diversi talenti di emergere e la stessa
cosa facciamo spesso nelle
organizzazioni è per questo che io credo
che l'organizzazione oggi rappresenti e
possono rappresentare un limite alle
sfide che noi abbiamo scienze e
tecnologie
questo è un campo naturalmente che ha
fatto parte della mia vita e quindi ci
sono dentro ma da un po di tempo cerco
di ripensarci
non sono solo io che ho dico questo ma
recentemente ho pensato veramente che il
rischio che noi corriamo è quello
dell'eni potenza della scienza e poi
della tecnologia ma perché sin
dall'ottocento ma su tutto il novecento
sarà un secolo straordinario avete
ascoltato cosa oggi noi sappiamo da un
punto di vista genetico
cosa possiamo fare da un punto di vista
genetico ma anche ma anche la mia grande
scoperta è che in realtà c'è ancora
molto che non sappiamo
io torno l'antico io so di non sapere un
po di umiltà ci serve perché in realtà
ogni qual volta andiamo a vedere che
quello che noi pensiamo di sapere e
sicuramente almeno leggermente diverso
nella genetica
oggi comincia a emergere tutto una
branca che si chiama e vi genetica che
ci pone un sacco di problemi su come ci
si rapporta con la natura come la natura
influisce su
il suo genoma e quindi in realtà noi
ancora conosciamo poco
questa è una frase sbagliata e poi
magari qualcuno lo capirà me lo dirà
quello che qui voglio dire che
l'intervento di prima magari è
leggermente diverso prima di arrivare ad
avere un innovazione di successo c'è una
quantità di prove che falliscono la
maggioranza dei processi dei progetti di
innovazione falliscono e ce ne sono
anche alcuni molto buoni però falliscono
noi in realtà oggi tendiamo sempre a
premiare e riconoscere il successo è un
bel problema perché senza insuccesso non
ci sarebbe successo ancora una volta
bisogna guardarla in maniera diversa
se non riusciamo a guardare in maniera
diversa rischiamo di bloccare la
capacità di innovazione
il pericolo è quello delle generazioni
super tecnologiche io avevo niente
contro anzi io sono un amante della
tecnologia utilizza la tecnologia però
il rischio è che le generazioni su e
tecnologici e penso che anche una volta
uno strumento a tecnologia possa
risolvere tutti i problemi e invece
questo non è vero
anche perché arriverà qualche cosa che
noi non prevediamo che cambierà la
situazione e guardate noi abbiamo oggi
una grandissima quantità di informazioni
come i maya abbiamo avuto sappiamo che i
sistemi sono complessi la nostra
capacità di prevedere che cosa succede
in un sistema complesso e più o meno
equivalente a quello degli antichi ci
sono moltissimi i denti che lo
dimostrano
e perché perché è un sistema complesso è
fatta da moltissime variabili che sono
interdipendenti e la cui relazione non è
neanche lineare quindi è un macello
ancora oggi noi non sappiamo bene
come funziona il nostro metabolismo sono
difficili da rilevare e noi non possiamo
un sistema complesso cercare di
osservarlo da un componente e dedurre il
sistema se io guardo il mio fegato non
posso capire come è fatto il mio
organismo
e allora alla fine alla fine io credo
che voi siete degli sperimentatori siamo
sperimentatori ogni giorno il problema è
che molto spesso quando sperimentiamo
falliamo e dovremmo avere poca paura di
fallire soprattutto dovremmo insegnare
ai nostri figli a non avere paura di
fallire
dobbiamo uscire dagli schemi perché
senza uscire dagli schemi non riusciamo
a risolvere i problemi che abbiamo di
fronte e quindi dobbiamo essere sempre
gentili pacati ma sempre rompiscatole
grazie